[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france24 comenzamos con derramas un
proyecto regional que tiene como
objetivo apoyar a comunidades amazónicas
en la lucha contra la deforestación y
ayudar al desarrollo sostenible de sus
tierras de ramaz qué es la unión de las
palabras territorios amazónicos es una
colaboración entre varias organizaciones
francesas con financiamiento de la
agencia francesa de desarrollo que
invirtió 9 millones y medio de euros en
este proyecto piloto la mayor cantidad
de dinero no reembolsable jamás dedicada
por esta agencia en américa latina' por
ahora incluye cinco regiones de cuatro
países de la amazonía contigua sur y
paragominas en brasil madre de dios en
perú guaviare en colombia y el parque
yasuní en ecuador para conocer más
detalles de esta iniciativa conversé con
miriam bus la ma directora de la agencia
francesa de desarrollo en colombia
el objetivo general es brindar
herramientas técnicas para apoyar la
planificación y la gestión social
sostenible de los territorios amazónicos
yo te puedo contar con un poco más de
detalle el proyecto piloto que vamos a
desarrollar en colombia lo van a operar
varias entidades primero centro de
cooperación internacional e
investigación agronómica para el
desarrollo una institución francés junto
con el psoe o ene efe andina que es luís
nacional de fue otra institución
francesa y también con una institución
que se llama a bs.f agrónomos y
veterinarios sin fronteras sin fronteras
entonces estas tres instituciones están
estos tres entes técnicos van a estar
trabajando con los entes territoriales y
en particular en este caso con el
guaviare para eran de poner en marcha
estas herramientas y ayudar a la toma de
decisión sobre la planificación y el uso
de los suelos
y explorar oportunidades para un proceso
de certificación de territorios para
aprender a producir de forma más
sostenible
y de forma transversal contribuir a la
lucha contra la deforestación y el
desarrollo de un sistema agrícola y
forestal que sea realmente sostenible
también entrevistamos al embajador de
francia en colombia gautier miño sobre
los intereses de su país en la
conservación de la amazonía
hay que recordar que francia también es
país amazónico a través de la ruina
francesa que tiene un 23 por ciento de
la selva amazónica la evolución de
desastrosa de la amazonía a nivel de
deforestación a nivel de incendios nos
afecta a todos no solamente a los países
amazónicos a todo el planeta por
supuesto a través a través de la pérdida
de biodiversidad
[Música]
la amazonía alberga más o menos el 50
por ciento de la biodiversidad mundial
pero también es una reserva de agua
potable e inmensa 15 al 20% de las
reservas de agua potable del planeta y
cerca del 10 por ciento de las reservas
de carbono es un pozo de carbón entonces
es muy importante de mantener este pozo
de carbono si queremos lograr los
objetivos del accord parís y luchar
contra el cambio climático el embajador
resaltaba la importancia del trabajo
conjunto de la comunidad internacional
para la preservación de estos
ecosistemas que son tan claves para el
equilibrio ambiental del planeta algo
con lo que está de acuerdo la directora
de la agencia francesa de desarrollo en
colombia
tenemos que elevar un poco más la voz de
esta de este asunto de crisis
de crisis climática en realidad estamos
yo creo más allá de la crisis estamos en
una fase de transición ecológica y casi
irreversible entonces la necesidad de
abogar a favor de la urgencia
de luchar contra el cambio climático la
deforestación la reducción de las
emisiones de co2 pasa primero por esta
coalición de actores estas alianzas
internacionales
para justamente movilizar crear una
movilización un loving reforzar el
loving
a favor de esta causa que algún día
va a ser extremamente problemática si no
lo hacemos y si no nos ponemos ahora
mismo al serlo terram haces parte de los
100 millones de euros de inversión en la
cuenca amazónica que el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón anunció hace
exactamente un año durante la asamblea
general de las naciones unidas
y finalizamos este programa con el día
mundial de la limpieza que se celebra
anualmente el 19 de septiembre y que
este año tuvo que llevarse a cabo en su
mayoría de manera virtual
precisamente el mundo virtual internet
es uno de los crecientes motores de
contaminación en el mundo cada email
vídeo que vemos en el clics o fotos que
guardamos en la nube ocupan un espacio
en los servidores que consumen unas
grandes cantidades de energía y por ende
contribuyen a las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero dedicado la barría
con los detalles este año muchos eventos
fueron anulados a causa de la crisis
sanitaria
virginie que dirige el día de la
limpieza del planeta en francia pensó
entonces en una jornada de aseo
cibernético internet y las nuevas
tecnologías que son el cuarto emisor de
gases de efecto invernadero antes
incluso que aeronáutica pero pocos lo
saben
en nuestra casa tenemos a menudo muchas
cosas y cuando los muebles se llenan
debemos regalar dos pero nuestro
ciberespacio no sabemos lo que hay
detrás y nos da la impresión que es
infinito y que podemos guardar sin
límites pero debemos pensar que
materialmente está en alguna parte que
ocupa el espacio y el objetivo es
suprimir lo que no necesitamos yo que me
siento nervioso limpie su teléfono móvil
su ordenador y su buzón de correo
electrónico son buenos gestos para
comenzar
es todo por estas semanas sigan con más
medio ambiente en france 24 punto com
[Música]